herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
in den kommenden monaten werden die
meisten von uns eine völlig neue
erfahrung machen nämlich die dass ein
lebenswichtiges gut nicht für alle
verfügbar ist zumindest nicht sofort
und was das bedeutet das haben wir seit
heute schwarz auf weiß
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen hat
eine verordnung unterschrieben die
regelt wer sich in welcher reihenfolge
gegen cupid 19 impfen lassen kann
das ist eine schwierige frage es geht es
nicht um den impfstoff von biotech und
pfizer der aller voraussicht nach
zugelassen wird in den kommenden tagen
und der erst nach und nach produziert
werden kann
und die frage ist deshalb so wichtig
weil nun ganz klar geregelt werden muss
wer sich wann die potenziell
lebensrettende spritze abholen kann eine
schwierige frage die die bundesregierung
nun heute beantwortet hat die
schwächsten zu schützen das ist das
erste ziel unserer impfkampagne
zur wahrheit gehört dass wir mindestens
ein bis zwei monate brauchen werden bis
wir dieses ziel erreicht haben deswegen
bitte ich alle anderen bürgerinnen und
bürger um geduld
ich bitte sie darum abzuwarten bis auch
sie an der reihe sind
er bittet um geduld und viele dürfen
diese geforderte geduld nur schwer
aufbringen
vielleicht weil sie angst vor kurve 19
haben vielleicht weil sie eine wichtige
position haben wichtige aufgaben
vielleicht weil sie ihre freiheiten
wiederhaben wollen jeder hat er seine
eigenen gründe und das wirft natürlich
auch ethische fragen auf zum beispiel
die frage wie sehr diese reihenfolge
überhaupt ist oder überhaupt sein kann
klären wollen wir diese fragen mit
jemandem der sich da sehr gut auskennt
in berlin sprechen wir mit dem
humangenetiker professor doktor wolfram
henn er ist mitglied im deutschen
ethikrat und stellvertretender
vorsitzender der zentralen
ethikkommission der bundesärztekammer
guten abend herr professor hin guten
morgen vor richtern
der deutsche ethikrat hatte ja im
november ein positionspapier erstellt
zusammen mit der ständigen
impfkommission und der leopoldina und da
haben sie eine priorisierung empfohlen
die ja gar nicht so viel anders war als
die die nun herr sparen verordnet hat
heute heißt das sie sind zumindest
inhaltlich zufrieden mit dieser
verordnung ja durchaus
wir sind in einer lage wie sie es gerade
eben völlig richtig geschildert haben
die beispiellos in der jüngeren
deutschen geschichte dass es bücher gibt
die nicht für alle verfügbar sind und da
muss man eben nach ethischen und
parallel praktischen kriterien zu ordnen
treffen damit man möglichst viel
gewinnen an lebenschancen für möglichst
viele menschen möglichst früh haben kann
aber das geht eben nicht ganz ohne
zuteilung maßnahmen der von welcher
reihenfolge wir überhaupt sprechen wer
in der warteschlange weiter nach vorne
darf wer sich eher hinten anstellen muss
das wollen wir euch jetzt zeigen die aus
der kurzen überblick geimpft werden soll
in mehreren stufen zuallererst sind
menschen über 80 jahre und pflegeheim
bewohner an der reihe
auch medizinisches personal mit sehr
hohem ansteckungsrisiko gehört dazu etwa
in notaufnahmen und solche mit engem
kontakt zu cupid 19 infizierten zur
stuhl
für zwei zellen ältere zwischen 70 und
79 jahren menschen mit demenz oder einer
geistigen behinderung die in
einrichtungen leben auch die hausärzte
gehören dazu und enge kontaktpersonen
von pflegebedürftigen und schwangeren
zur stufe 3 gehören personen ab 60
jahren und solche mit erhöhtem risiko
für einen schweren verlauf einer corona
infektion auch mitarbeiter besonders
relevanter berufe zählen dazu zb polizei
feuerwehr und erzieher zuletzt kommen
alle anderen menschen unter 60 jahren
und ohne vorerkrankungen an die reihe
ja das ist die reihenfolge über die wir
jetzt weiter sprechen wollen mit
professor doktor henn dem übrigens auch
ihr eure fragen stellen könnt zum
beispiel per e mail an diese e mail
adresse professorin wir haben hier im
livestream erfahrungsgemäß viele junge
zuschauer von dienst bestimmt einige
jetzt fragen warum sie so lange warten
müssen schließlich verlieren sie eine
besonders wichtige zeit jetzt wenn sie
ihre freiheiten nicht haben
vielleicht haben sie auch mehr zu
verlieren weil sie jung sind viele jahre
verlieren würden wenn sie erkranken
würden schwer oder sogar sterben würden
an cupid 19
sind solche gedanken legitim solche
gedanken sind legitim man muss sie eben
zu ende führen man muss sie auch ganz
nüchtern wissenschaftlich bewerten die
überlegung liegt erstmal nach zu sagen
na ja wer die meisten lebensjahr noch zu
gewinnen hat der möge zuerst geimpft
werden aber es ist im interesse aller
wenn man umgekehrt vorgeht denn die
wichtigste notwendigkeit in der nächsten
zeit ist es unsere intensivstationen zu
entlasten und die entlastet man am
besten dadurch dass man diejenigen
zuerst ihm die wenn sie krank wird mit
dem höchsten risiko mit der höchsten
wahrscheinlichkeit intensiv wichtig
werden wenn wir da mit den jungen
anfangen würden hätten wir wenig gewinn
hier schreibt auf youtube ein user
michael lindner
da ist eher ob wir freiheiten
zurückbekommen fragezeichen
ausrufezeichen keine regierung auch
nicht frau merkel hat das recht uns
beziehungsweise irgendjemand dass
freiheit überhaupt einzuschränken nach
dem was sie bisher gesagt haben sie
stimmen ihnen sicherlich nicht zu sich
das richtig
nicht in diesem maße fähig sollte man
sich bewusst machen wir sind ständig
täglich freiheitseinschränkung
notwendige art ausgesetzt wenn wir bei
rot an der ampel halten wir auch in
unserer bewegungsfreiheit platz kurz
eingeschränkt aber jeder sieht dass das
vernünftig ist und so müssen wir hier
auch vorgehen es gibt nun mal nicht
genug impfstoff für alle von anfang an
also müssen wir eine faire und
transparente zuteilung machen und ich
glaube das haben wir in den letzten
monaten wirklich ganz gut hinbekommen
dass da nicht alle glücklich mit sind
ist völlig klar
indonesien macht es übrigens genau
andersrum da setzt man darauf dass mir
zuerst die jungen die gesunden impft in
deutschland wir haben es eben gehört ist
es andersrum
und da müssen wohl auch diejenigen
jüngeren menschen warten die tatsächlich
zur risikogruppe gehören
und wir haben einen betroffenen gefragt
was er von dieser entscheidung hält ja
mein name ist konstantin grosch ich bin
28 jahre alt lebe in einer eigenen
häuslichkeit mit pflegern in einer
rundum-betreuung weil ich einen
rollstuhlfahrer bin ich habe eine
muskelerkrankung die dazu führt dass die
muskelkraft in meinem gesamten körper
zunehmend abbaut und das betrifft unter
anderem auch solche organe wie lunge
hilfs muskulatur oder auch das herzen
junger menschen die zur risikogruppe
zählen zwar zu hochrisikogruppe wir
reden über menschen die beatmet werden
die trotzdem in der eigenen häuslichkeit
wohnen oder von angehörigen betreut
werden die fallen durch all diese raster
in diesen verordnungen und maßnahmen das
ist jetzt bei dem impfstoff der fall das
war aber vorher auch schon bei
unterschiedlichsten maßnahmen der fall
das heißt wir fühlen uns völlig
schutzlos und das muss ich auch deutlich
sagen von vorne bis hinten vergessen
durch die politik und insbesondere durch
das gesundheitsministerium weil wir eben
weder einen aktiven noch einen passiven
schutz erhalten und mindestens 1 müsste
eben gegeben sein wenn wir uns die
prozentualen risikogruppen anschauen
dann werden wir sehr schnell feststellen
dass insbesondere hoch
intensivpflegebedürftige auch junge
menschen oder gerade junge menschen
genauso risiko belastet sind wenn nicht
sogar noch mehr
diese werden aber nirgendwo aufgeführt
insofern glaube ich ist das sehr
undifferenziert wie wir derzeit in die
aktuelle lage hinein gehen
herr professor hände haben wir
sicherlich eine sehr legitime forderung
gehört was würden sie herrn grosch
antworten bzw hinzufügen persönlich
bedauere ich die situation sehr ich hab
selber mit muskeldystrophie und
muskelerkrankungen von berufswegen zu
tun ich kenne die problematik bei diesen
menschen handelt es sich oben leute die
ganz objektiv und nüchtern betrachtet im
durchschnitt weniger hohe sterberisiko
unter einer erkrankung rahmen wie die
ganz alte das ist tatsächlich
epidemiologisch so gesichert und
menschen mit chronischen definierten
lungen erkrankten sind mit erhöhtem
risiko belastet und kommen dann recht
schnell aber eben nicht von anfang an
aber doch recht schnell nach den
hochbetagten wobei bei den hochbetagten
hat man auch noch das logistische zu
beachten dass die ja vielfach in
pflegeeinrichtungen sind wo dann im
teams aktiv in die einrichtungen
hineingehen das kann man sehr schnell
bewerkstelligen es knirscht an allen
ecken enten dass menschen mit solchen
chronischen erkrankungen vergessen
worden sind das ist nicht der fall es
sind ganz ganz schwierige abwägungen die
im einzelfall immer wieder dann auch als
ungerecht erlebt werden ich verstehe das
menschlich gut aber ich kann das problem
nicht lösen
und das kann auch kein ministerium
verschiedene berufsgruppen fordern ja
dass sie in der warteschlange weiter
nach vorne rücken zum beispiel die
lehrer oder auch die die ärzte haben
sich heute auch noch mal explizit
geäußert und diese forderung gestellt
bevor minister sparen die verordnung
unterschrieben hat argumentiert wird wir
sind einem hohen risiko ausgesetzt in
unseren berufsalltag und wir sind
systemrelevant wie wichtig und legitim
aus ethischer sicht sind diese argumente
auch diese argumente sind legitime
müssen eine abstufung vornehmen nach der
objektiven dringlichkeit und da ist es
einfach so dass menschen in
systemrelevanten berufen nur eine sehr
große gruppe darstellen die in ihrem
durchschnitt eben
etwas mehr gefährdet sind als die
durchschnittsbevölkerung denken wir
beispielsweise an ordnungskräfte polizei
oder feuerwehr
die benötigt werden für das
funktionieren der gesellschaft die aber
im gegensatz beispielsweise zu
bettlägerigen älteren menschen auch die
chance haben sich durch ihr eigenes
verhalten zu schützen und das ist auch
eine sonder aspekt der menschen mit
geistiger behinderung betrifft die aus
diesem grund weise eben nicht die
möglichkeit haben sich durch gezieltes
eigenes verhalten hinreichen zu schützen
ein stück nach oben gerückt worden sind
das ist ein ganz schwieriger balance
prozess er ist jetzt an dieser stelle
abgeschlossen worden irgendwann muss ja
klarheit herrschen damit auch die
abläufe gestaltet werden können ich
verstehe das alles menschlich gut und
wir werden natürlich gerne alle
priorisieren aber wie es natürlich so
funktioniert das nicht
ja zumal man nach gleichzeitig sagen
muss welche gruppen dann natürlich
gleichzeitig nach hinten weiter rutschen
das hat immer hätte es immer die andere
seite der medaille
wie wichtig ist die frage der verteilung
denn überhaupt für die akzeptanz in der
bevölkerung was die impfungen angeht
das ist ein ganz wichtiger aspekt wir
wären ja hoffentlich recht bald
sozusagen ein umkippen der problematik
haben dahin gehen dass wenn die
hochrisikogruppen durchgeimpft sind und
dann gleichzeitig genug impfstoff für
alle da ist dass man dann eben menschen
motivieren muss den impfstoff der ihnen
dann angeboten wird und kostenlos
angeboten wird und übrigens das wird oft
vergessen mit einer versicherung
staatlichen versicherung gegen die
nebenwirkung dass diese menschen die
allgemeinheit daneben auch die
impfstoffe in anspruch nimmt und die
motivation dadurch weiter an anfang
geschaffen dann nämlich wenn die erste
verteilung fair und transparent abläuft
und genau darum geht es jetzt vielleicht
an dieser stelle ein kurzer hinweis an
unsere user wir bekommen viele fragen
die allerdings medizinische fragen sind
und keine ethischen ich denke mal
professor dr hin ist zwar mediziner aber
als ethiker heute bei uns und das ist
jetzt heute nicht seine aufgabe also
wenn es um ethische fragen geht immer
gerne her
mit die medizinischen fragen die
behandeln wir dann in anderen sendungen
leiden wir noch mal beim thema akzeptanz
herr professor hin
es handelt sich ja hier um eine
verordnung das heißt die bundesregierung
hat entschieden in welcher reihenfolge
geimpft werden kann und darf und soll es
war nicht das parlament sie haben
gefordert mit ihrem positionspapier wird
dass wir eben schon gesprochen haben
dass es eines gesetzes bedarf spricht
dass das parlament diskutiert darüber
dass das parlament also die gewählten
volksvertreter darüber entscheiden und
dadurch eine eine breitere
diskussionsgrundlage überhaupt zu dieser
fahrt und beziehungsweise zu der
reihenfolge führt reicht eine verordnung
ihrer meinung nach auch bei einer so
wichtigen essentiellen frage die so
viele menschen betrifft
ich bin darüber persönlich nicht ganz
glücklich und auch die priorisierung
empfehlung des ethikrates und der
wissenschaftsakademie hat das eigentlich
durchaus angemahnt dass eine so
schwerwiegende verteilungs entscheidung
die ja für diejenigen die hinter
angestellt werden dann auch wirkliche
lebensbedrohliche probleme machen kann
eigentlich einer parlamentarischen
behandlung bedürfe aber es ist nicht die
aufgabe der politikberatung politik zu
machen
es ist jetzt so gestaltet worden ich
glaube inhaltlich gibt es jetzt keine
verwerfung aber vom verfahren her sage
ich jetzt mal persönlich wäre mir eine
direkte beteiligung des parlamentes
schon lieber gewesen
da war mir auch mal hören was die
parlamentarier selbst zu sagen haben
alle voran geäußert hat sich heute der
generalsekretär der fdp volker wissing
und das waren seine argumente unsere
verfassung sagt die wesentlichen grund
rechtsfragen muss das parlament
entscheiden
für mich ist das eindeutig eine
wesentliche grundrechts frage in welcher
reihenfolge menschen die den schutz der
impfung bekommen der am ende den schutz
ihres lebens bedeuten kann
also wenn man sich diese zeit genommen
hätte das kann innerhalb von zwei tagen
drei tagen geschehen
dann hätte man eine ganz sichere
grundlage ich möchte mich noch mal hier
auf meine user die und schreiben noch
mal konzentrieren da gehen nämlich
einige fragen in die richtung
ob es wirklich sinnvoll ist die älteren
priorisiert zu impfen ob es nicht besser
wäre die jüngeren die das virus
vielleicht weiter verbreiten die nicht
isoliert leben wollen können die ihre
freiheiten haben wollen die in die
schule gehen wollen
hier schreibt zum beispiel anja kühne
dass die schatten familie seit monaten
vergessen werden jetzt zerbrechen was
sagen sie dazu
ja das ist ganz bitter und das ist eine
wirklich schwierige überlegung aber die
epidemiologie wir müssen uns da zunächst
einmal auf die haare der wissenschaft
stützen sagt klipp und klar wenn wir in
der jetzigen situation wo die
intensivstationen am überlaufen sind
nicht schnellstmöglich diejenigen gruppe
neben ver.di die überbelastung der
intensivstation hauptsächlich verursacht
und das sind nun mal die eltern dann
haben auch jünger und öffentlich nur ein
kurve denken dürfen auch an herzinfarkt
oder unfälle denken haben dann keine
chancen mehr wenn sie dann tatsächlich
intensiv wichtig werden ein
entsprechendes bett zu bekommen um von
daher ist es sowohl ethisch denken wir
alle dran was den menschen in den heimen
zugemutet worden ist und eben auch
pragmatisch um das besonders system zu
entlassen geht es in die gleiche
richtung und deshalb ist die
entscheidung so gefallen die hoffnung
nicht gerne aber notwendig
die hoffnung ist ja groß dass diejenigen
die geimpft sind nicht nur selber immun
sind sondern auch das virus nicht weiter
verbreiten so weit ich informiert bin
braucht es da aber noch
wissenschaftliche abklärungen und die
empfehlung ist erstmal weiter maske zu
tragen
damit dürfte auch eine user frage wieder
beantwortet sein aber nehmen wir an
sollte es tatsächlich so sein stellt
sich heraus man verbreitet das virus
wirklich nicht weiter und man dürfte
sich aus virologischen medizinischen
gründen wieder frei bewegen wie ist das
aus ethischen gesichtspunkten sollten
diejenigen die dann eigentlich wieder
könnten sich trotzdem an die gleichen
regeln halten wie alle die noch warten
müssen auf ihre impfung das ist
irgendwie
die schwierige frage die auch unter
wissenschaftlern wissenschaftler aus der
ethik umstritten ist
ich führe es selber am wichtigsten
das argument an dass man die ordnung
auch strukturiert haben muss stellen sie
sich vor sie werden polizistinnen und
würden durch den park gehen und da
werden einige leute mit masken einige
leute ohne unterwegs dann könnten sie
einfach gar nicht sicherstellen
die klärung herbeizuführen wer ist jetzt
masken verweigerung objektiv noch
gefährlich wäre es schon geimpft also
ich glaube wir müssen in dieser
übergangsphase die ja hoffentlich kurz
sein wird und je mehr motivation wir
kriegen umso kürzer wird sie seien dann
auch gewisse einschränkungen hinnehmen
auch wenn sie im einzelfall vielleicht
nicht wirklich sinnvoll sind
es sind notwendig um den gesamten ablauf
zu sichern fragen wir mal andersrum was
ist ab dem zeitpunkt wo alle geimpft
sind die geimpft werden wollen und nur
noch die übrig bleiben die die die sich
gegen eine impfung entscheiden
der chef der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung andreas kasten hatte
gestern gefordert dass alle
schutzmaßnahmen dann eigentlich
zurückgenommen werden sollten zitat wer
sich nicht impfen lassen wolle müsse
dann auch mit dem risiko leben ankommt
19 zu erkranken oder gar daran zu
sterben ist es legitim einen solchen
punkt zu setzen oder greifen solche
forderungen zu kurz bedenkt man dazu
wenig mit also da muss ich den kollegen
wissenschaftlich medizinisch
widersprechen
zum einen gibt es zwar wenige aber zu
beachtende bevölkerungsgruppen die aus
medizinischen gründen nicht geimpft
werden können weise schwere
immunsuppression haben
zum anderen wirken die impfstoffe jahren
in anführungszeichen nur nach
derzeitigen daten zu 95% schützend und
von daher kann man nicht einfach sagen
nadel rein maske weg und alle probleme
sind gelöst da muss man schon behutsam
angehen und man muss auch parallel zu
dem ausrollen der impfstoffe
entsprechende studien betreiben so
einfach wird es nicht sein
aber im schnitt weit gebe ich eher
gelassen dann
recht dass menschen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen dann auch damit
rechnen müssen zwar keine staatlichen
sanktionen zu bekommen ihm pflicht wird
es ja nicht geben aber eben gewissen
nachteilen sich gegenüber zu sehen
beispielsweise gar nicht mehr gut
vorstellen und ich finde das auch
gerechtfertigt dass der betreiber eines
fitnessstudios sagt bei mir bekommt nur
einen abonnement wenn er einen
impfnachweis mit führt klar natürlich
das alles kann erst dann sinnvoll sein
und legitim sagen wenn wirklich alle die
chance hatten geht zu werden da brauchen
wir noch ein paar monaten ja impfen
wollen oder eben nicht wollen darüber
entspinnt sich auch eine diskussion hier
bei uns im chat zb schreibt dominik
schweer er kennt niemanden der die
impfung will ich glaube die antwort
finden wir ebenfalls im selben chat zum
beispiel von frau meier die sagt egal
wie alt man kann froh sein wenn man in
den berufsgruppen tätig ist wo impfung
pflicht ist oder hier haben wir engel
maria auf facebook ich lasse mich auf
alle fälle impfen und denke dann meine
gefährdeten mitmenschen das schimpft
sich solidarität und da würde ich gerne
noch mal diese frage die da drin ja
steckt an sie weitergeben wenn jetzt
sagen viele ich lasse mich nicht impfen
das ist ja durchaus legitim zu sagen ich
möchte nicht gleichzeitig muss man
natürlich bedenken dass das auch
auswirkungen auf andere hat dass man
dadurch natürlich das risiko erhöht dass
man andere ansteckt ist es also legitim
zu sagen nein ich ziehe mich der info
also es ist legal aber es ist ein stück
ihm das ist jetzt eine weit verbreitete
position in der ethik dass wir als
menschen eben nicht nur uns selbst
gegenüber sondern auch unseren
mitmenschen gegenüber verantwortung
tragen und das kann durchaus so weit
gehen dass wir unannehmlichkeiten in
kauf nehmen müssen immer mal ein
beispiel einer etwas wilderen
katastrophe eine flutkatastrophe da wird
jeder sofort sagen natürlich mache ich
mir da die füße nass um andere leute aus
dem wasser zu ziehen
und grundsätzlich ist diese pandemie
auch nichts anderes wenn sie auch nicht
so lautstark ist
wir müssen durch die impfung auch wenn
wir kleine unannehmlichkeiten und
wirklich minimale risiken das ist
eigentlich völlig klar
durch die impfung gewärtigen daneben
auch dieser doppel verantwortung und
selbst und anderen gegenüber genügen das
ist nur notwendigkeiten deshalb finde
ich in verweigerung ohne individuelle
gründe eben gerade nicht legitim wenn
sie auch legal ist in dem sinne dass sie
nicht straff verfolgt wird
darf ich aus ihrer anschluss folgen dass
sie sich persönlich impfen lassen
genau am ersten tag an dem mir der
impfstoff zugeschlagen wird nach den
allgemein geltenden regeln werde ich den
impfstoff mir zukommen lassen vielleicht
noch eine kleine ergänzung ich bin seit
über 30 jahren genetiker und wenn ich
die wahl habe sollte zwischen dem neuen
rna impfstoff und einem konventionellen
impfstoff werde ich wie die meisten
profis auf diesem gebiet den erna
impfstoff bevorzugen der ist noch besser
als der andere eine frage möchte ich
noch weiter reichen die uns auf youtube
erreicht habe und gerade vor meinen
augen glaube ich gelöscht wurde ich
schon wieder weg deswegen stelle ich ihn
dann doch meine nächste frage
die westlichen großen reichen
industrienationen haben sich große taten
schaden gesichert des impfstoffes
hunderte millionen
alle betonen wie wichtig es ist eine
gerechte verteilung auf der ganzen welt
zu erreichen das hören wir immer wieder
egal ob von der un oder den einzelnen
staaten den regierungschef in und chefin
chef wird genüge getan um dieses ziel
auch tatsächlich zu erreichen und diesem
anspruch zu genügen
und wenn ich mich da in die haut der
politik begeben würde ich mich ziemlich
unwohl fühlt muss ich sagen klar ist zum
einen jeder ist erst mal für sein
eigenes land verantwortlich aber
natürlich darf da keine america first
politik geben sondern wir müssen auch im
eigenen interesse übrigens zugleich
unsere eigene bevölkerung versorgen als
auch dafür sorge tragen dass in anderen
ländern wo die gesundheitssysteme
schlechter sind wo dann aber erdiger
reservoirs aufkommen bürger mit der zeit
impfung zu ermöglichen da werden schon
politische linien gezogen aber im moment
ist es so man fühlt sich ehrlich gesagt
nicht so ganz toll damit aber das eben
die deutschen die europäer in europa
mehr ein länderübergreifendes
versorgungssystem am anfang stehen aber
wir müssen alles tun dass wir möglichst
schnell dann auch eine weltweite
versorgung hinbekommen da sind wir eben
direkt ja schon meinem geld bei der
frage und jetzt habe ich auch die
wiedergefunden die eben verschwunden war
von mistral auf reis über youtube wie
ethisch ist es das was am sonntag jetzt
die großen gewinne einstreichen
jedes unter dem muss leben muss seine
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter bezahlen die
preise sind soweit man das von außen
sehen kann ziemlich knapp kalkuliert und
was da läuft ist legitim es wurden ja
auch enorme investitionen getätigt
wurden auch risiken eingegangen die
karas durch staatliche garantien
abgefedert worden sind unsere wirtschaft
und dazu gehört eben auch die
pharmazeutische industrie würde nicht
funktionieren die wird auch keine
forschungseinrichtungen haben wenn sie
da habe ich verdienen könnte also die
goldene nase wird zwar nicht geben aber
dass gewinne ihr legitim sind dass es im
wirtschaftsleben über also das finde ich
nicht schlimm ist eine frage von
facebook möchte ich ihnen noch weiter
reichen von
sabrina wer entscheidet bei dementen
menschen ohne angehörige der gesetzliche
vormund wissen sie das können sie uns
die frage beantworten also eine impfung
ist karl bestands mäßig ein eingriff in
die körperliche integrität das geht
nicht ohne einwilligung entweder durch
den menschen selbst oder wenn dieser
mensch selbst nicht einigen kann durch
eine stellvertretende einwilligung und
das ist bei menschen mit demenz in aller
regel dann ein vom amtsgericht vom
betreuungsgericht eingestellter
gesetzlicher betreuer meistens
angehörige es gibt auch berufs
betreuerinnen und betreuer über die muss
das ganze laufen das ist übrigens eine
handfeste logistische verantwortung und
aufgabe denen sich die heime jetzt
stellen müssen das über die ehemaligen
betreuer zu organisieren also kommt eine
menge arbeit auf die heime zu und an
dieser stelle soll auch mal gesagt
werden dass die allgemeinheit im sinne
von besseren personal ständen auch in
der verantwortung ist das ans laufen
mitzubringen ist ein sehr schwieriger
aufgaben der jahreswechsel steht uns
bevor viele werden das jahr 2020 nicht
sehr vermissen was wünschen sie uns
allen für 2021 genug impfstoff genug
impfstoff akzeptanz durch laufende in
foren und ich glaube das wird man selbst
verstärkender mechanismus sein wenn es
bei den ersten gut klappt jetzt an die
anderen motivieren
und dann hoffe ich dass wir mit dem
schönen wetter im frühjahr dann in einem
sommer reinkommt ein bisschen
komfortabler wird und am ende sollten
wir unterm weihnachtsbaum 2021 wieder so
sitzen die was 2009 10 hatten und dann
haben wir's geschafft ein schönes
positives schlussbild mit dem wer
professor doch zuschauern natürlich auch
sie in das wochenende entlassenen ein
viertes adventwochenende das etwas
ruhiger werden dürfte als ein übliches
wochenende vor weihnachten
ich hoffe sie werden es gut verbringen
können professor dr in vielen dank an
sie alle
dringlich und zuschauen und auf
wiedersehen schönen abend